got it eventually
so win four draws win
this this is classical chess you know
pick up a win here and there that's all
you can ask for really
okay let's go e6
okay bishop g5
i just wanted to play
a hedgehog type of position
let's go c5 then trade on d4
hp7
too much bs in chat somebody's saying
can't argue with that
okay there is there are some more
aggressive ways to set up with bishop f6
there but i
deferred castling a little bit
in order not to in order to be
possibly be able to castle coincide in
case he starts attacking on the king
side
now this is generally quite solid for
black
i'm i don't love the fact that i played
h6
so i might want to put the bishop around
but yeah you can't have it all
probably going to end up yeah setting up
a head check structure so that's the one
i got now
why is this color keep changing it's
kind of funny
okay let's go knight h5 trade a little
bit
generally speaking i'm doing doing fine
slightly slightly worse because of the
space but my position is very
um very solid and
potentially i do have a couple of pawn
breaks with e5 and b5
now i'll just trade knight f6 back
and yeah life is
not good then at least decent
queen f4
don't know what that does it's attacking
this one but i'll go b5
and then i'm also covering that square
i think he's playing a little bit
softly here now i get queen b7 and i
think
structurally
i have a slight advantage um
since i will be able to
create some kind of minority minority
attack on them
on the queen side and compared to normal
coral quincy structures my pawn is still
on d6 not on d5
and that that means that these squares
are covered for his knight
and um that makes my position a little
more flexible
you can also exchange queens but let's
not
let's not rock the boats
um so how to progress now
group a4 is interesting
b3 i will view that as a weakness
and maybe just go back otherwise i want
to take over the a
if a file and whenever he takes ba4
this pawn becomes weak
so i'm trying to exchange everything on
the
on the queen side here more or less and
then just
potentially have the better contracture
with these four or five against
these five or four if we exclude the
c three and d six pawns which
may also be exchanged eventually
yeah okay i'll take take rookie eight
so if i go over okay he has got c4 which
is annoying me
yeah let's just take rook e8
if he takes takes queen b5
queen a1 um
these damn arrows again
uh queen a1
knight f1 what's going wrong here
nevermind knight f1 queen c3 queen b8
king h7
queen d6 knight queen b3 blah blah blah
yeah slightly better
vlad is certainly taking his time now
okay knight f1
interesting
yeah let's go knight d5 queen
c3 knights queen b5 knight c3 looks good
also c4 knight f4 probably wins upon
she has to go g3 i believe
she duly has done
maybe i just have nothing here
i got nothing nothing is what i have
damn it
hmm yeah probably don't have anything
i'm somewhat up on time at least
let's exchange try and pretend that his
pawn is a bit weak
92 i think maybe d5
cd it's too little this is probably also
too
too little
might be five g4 maybe yeah i'm not the
dull better
okay draw
yeah there's a pattern